all right here's the first story we got
from The Daily Mail breaking news
Memphis cops released horrific video
five officers reigning punches and kicks
down on Tyree Nichols is that it
pronounce it Tyree Nichols I was calling
him Tire nickels before I couldn't tell
because like if it was Tyree I think
it'd be like two e's but I'm not trying
to get his name wrong goes to Tyree as
he screams out mom before dying in
hospital after cardiac arrest and kidney
failure so
they got a bunch of different angles
they pepper spray them they pin them on
the ground there's surveillance footage
where he's got his hands behind his back
they're holding I think they've cuffed
him at this point right yeah I think so
and then the cop just walks up and just
does full boom boom just starts wailing
you see him going back and forth yo it's
tough to watch yeah it's very tough to
watch and they had that uh that doc uh
I'm sorry the chief of police came out
earlier and said it's as worse or as bad
or worse than Rodney King and so I'm
kind of just like yo do they want people
to Riot tonight